and finally new rule Brian Williams
shouldn't have to go away because he
lied he should have to go away because
the NBC Nightly News sucks and so does
the CBS Evening News with Scott Pelley
and the ABC World News Tonight with I
think Ken hosted that one oh but Brian
Williams Brian Williams lie about the
helicopter that didn't destroy his
credibility with me ten years of wasting
precious News time on [ __ ] stories
about car chases and bears in a swimming
pool and store clerks fighting back and
returning soldiers surprising their kids
at the big game and Powerball jackpots
and that stupid [ __ ] Spanish tomato
fight that's what destroyed his
credibility with me so I know what
you're thinking who cares bill nobody
watches broadcast news anyway we get our
news the modern way from the video
screen at the gas station no actually
over nine million people watched Brian
Williams every night about 12 times more
than CNN delivering the news is a sacred
responsibility it's telling us the
important things we need to know it
shouldn't be a race to the bottom over
who can attract more eyeballs with
titillation if it is let's just get it
over with and show porn in the last
segment
and we're almost there the new thing is
just to show a YouTube clip that's gone
viral it's like the news brought to you
by your biggest stoner friend you know
it's not just it's not news just because
you have footage of something do I have
to see every building that's brought
down by a controlled explosion unless it
fell on my stash I don't care you have
22 minutes to bring us the world how
does that leave time for the four-minute
segment on the basset hound that found
his way home here's a crazy thought cut
the story where the high school
sweethearts reunite and get married at
80 and take an extra minute to link your
endless weather stories to climate
change
last year the NBC Nightly News spent a
total of 25 minutes all year on climate
change the most important issue of our
time this is journalistic malpractice
and it's why I never thought of Ryan
Williams as a reporter to begin with
because every night it's the same thing
on the news a couple of minutes at the
top of the big story of the day unless
God forbid it's going to snow it's gonna
snow on the East Coast you know where
they live and then nothing else is
happening in the entire world Ryan comes
to you live from the snow blower aisle
at Home Depot like white Godzilla is on
the way and then the same thing always
happens nothing it snows they plow it it
melts the end
oh the humidity this obsession with
weather on the national news is
especially bizarre because if there's
one thing that isn't national it's
weather it's snowing in Buffalo great
but it's always snowing in Buffalo and I
don't care I live in LA we don't need to
know about awful weather here awful
weather here is partly sunny
anyway after we get through with the
weather report and maybe some shots of
whatever photo-op the president arranged
that day it's time for the medical
segment which is usually on obesity and
a great excuse to run endless footage of
fat people whose faces we don't see
walking in the park sometimes alone
sometimes holding hands with other
fatties but always giant jiggly fat
people preferably on a park bench eating
ice cream to reinforce the message boy
these people are fat and then they
interview a doctor who says being fat
leads to obesity thanks doc and then
then the 22 minutes are almost up but
it's time for everyone's favorite part
of the broadcast the feel-good human
interest story because America you've
worked hard you've had to sit through
two maybe three minutes of hard news and
you deserve a break something to make
you think gosh maybe the world isn't so
bad after all so here's a story about a
paraplegic ice climber who scaled a
mountain a latchkey kid who ran a canned
food drive to cure cancer the pitcher er
won the big game to honor his dead twin
brother a hotel that welcomes guests
with rescue puppies a Minnesota high
school basketball team on a winning
streak an old black veteran who's blind
but he still drives the school bus yes
they're all great heartwarming stories
and there's a place for them it's called
Reader's Digest